leute noch eine kurze erinnerung
gefordert diese startet ich bin ja am 25
in einem nächsten samstag ist gar nicht
mehr so lange in oberhausen im zentrum
kommt auf jeden fall vorbei vor bescheid
sagen warten wir ein kleines zuschauern
und kleine zuschauer sehen wie viele
kommen schreibt eine kommentare in ihrem
staat bleibt und es wartet viel spaß mit
dem video video
ich hoffe es gibt auch ziemlich gut
ich möchte mich wieder mit einem werk
besonderen thema und war gehen uns heute
wieder um
ja du eigentlich mit eure
lieblingsthemen das letzte video auf
jeden fall wieder antrat angefangen
immer noch ziemlich gut an
damit für die kinder gerne bock hat auf
einem turm tour bei kunden room to life
ball tour ja da kommt vielleicht schon
morgen abend fällt nicht weiter und wird
nur bei morgen klappt müssen wir sehen
was ihr kater vom leben
ich habe mir überlegt und war gilt heute
umso mehr titelt und zehn probleme die
mädchen nicht verstehen ist über die
probleme die millionen farben die man
eigentlich auch nur als junge verstehen
kann
ich habe mich hingesetzt ich habe auch
ein paar von einer community gefragt was
versteht man nur als junger was ein
probleme von uns und da kam erzielten
viele probleme genau ich will aus lange
daran zu sagen wenn er bock drauf
natürlich sehen probleme die nur mädchen
verstehen
dann fällt auf jeden fall mitte neuer
problem in die kommentare
und dann kommt das video dazu am späten
sonntagabend lagen bei 15.000
gleichgesetzt
heute hören
online arbeitet die macher also
letztlich mit punkt jungen du machst du
wieder so ernst nimmt er doch auf 84
noch nazi-opfer hunger heute wenn ihm
ein video gestern alles gesehen hab
einfach nur geil findet ihr auf jeden
fall noch anschauen okay was auf der
erste punkt der betrieblich auch beim
heutigen nur und war weltweit morgen
hoffentlich brauchen neue jacke und hose
die zwei haben werden ist mir auf jeden
fall aber heute morgen gewählt und war
man gibt in jedem land ein wichtiger
spieler und du rennst du etwa einen
kilometer durch den ganzen laden bei
business partner gibt wieder ein hoch
und dann bis zu werten der
männerabteilung die frauenabteilung
getrickst und kilometerlange dann kommst
du die männerabteilung berührt wie die
lara mia da stehen dann für mich kiefer
zwei jacken hosen das wasser auch schon
arbeiter praktika jährige polizistin
ich war ja die mega also die hat mir
direkt und augen arbeit vergleich zu
sehr vom klima abhängig machen weiter
mit zwei ja auch hier fällt mir auch
sofort ein gefallen
ich habe ja keinen fußball gespielt und
ich bin mit meiner fußballerkarriere
pro jahr will ich sagen weil einen
richtig harten eier kommen und diese
schmerzen kann man sich nicht vorstellen
weil ein exempel und main-netz am
nächsten tag auch noch hat und man merkt
wollen die nächsten danach war das
irgendwie so in den bauch winzigkeit und
gefühlen war kurz anfangs ja natürlich
auch im team großen problem
je besser man sich in der schule
plötzlich muss man eine tafel denkt sich
abkommen das meist mal eben mit legt
geht an eine tafel und dann passiert ist
ein ganz bestimmtes teil am körper
spannend sich plötzlich an und erzeugt
eine kleine welle in der hose wenn die
katzenmutter und krieg plötzlich der
latte für mich eine frage der junge du
bist in der studie und krieg wirklich
mit lacroix die tafel
aber du kennt das man halt mal dürfen
krieg zwischen öffentlichen raum und
sich dann für den ausschaltet muss ich
aufpassen was zuerst scheint also kleine
fünkchen kein kommentar wir machen
weiter mit folgenden punkt an die etwas
jüngeren von euch die kinder zwar keine
doch nicht alle wetten werden wenn wir
jetzt auch die spüren bekommen vor allem
wenn ich ein junge sein und war das ist
mir schon wichtig so oft passieren man
setzt du kommen freitagabend an einem
gefäß voller hell weiß also breiter
graben samstagabend werden etwa weg mit
freunden einfach auf mein team
trinken bis 11 uhr geht dann richtig gut
gelaunt mit fünf kollegen in den club
rhein und wie so viele mädchen gehen wo
alle ein paar reihen an einen verein so
dann kommen wir an ruhr und einer kommt
nicht rein und es ist wirklich immer so
wurde nun für alle mädchen von reihen
kommen wir auch du rein in eine
kombination bekommt nicht sein und die
analysieren und dann ist der ganze abend
gelaufen an mitarbeiter mit dem nächsten
tor
das hilft mir auch passiert ich hab mir
dann kommt heute morgen warten deine
haare einfach mal nicht letztlich aus
ihren reihen gekommen
ein video zeigt dass du mich ganz schön
liegen problem waren
einfach diesen schritt dann kann man
doch eigentlich nicht machen wenn man
kurzarbeit auf bitten einiger arten gut
wissen und denken was dem mädchen zum
beispiel einfach lange habe die mit mir
erkennen ist natürlich auch aufwand aber
die sitzen doch eigentlich immer
natürlich kann ich verstehen wenn man
als mädchen auch an morgen denken mein
hauptjob nächste sache ist ganz einfach
das ist mir eigentlich auch erst
aufgefallen dagegen für bohlen wird zu
hause überhaupt kein problem einen tag
legen wie immer im kühlschrank gefüllt
und nächsten acht jahre für frank schöne
dass man immer mit cooler auswahl an
verschiedenen bretting an verschiedenen
dessert und so weiter hat probleme und
ganz einfach nur leute fragt mal auf ich
mache jemand beim kühlschrank aufstellt
die tour richtig schöner kühlschrank
einfach das standardmäßig ganze war dann
[Musik]
der cashflow aus
wir haben hier ein leckeres aktiv lassen
dann haben sie im kühlschrank
das war kein problem so von uns ja
probleme oder neun oder zehn ich weiß
nicht genau ich hoffe dass die darin
enthalten die gesagt hat als mädchen
die momentanen probleme verläuft bin
nicht wirklich alt durch bei 15.000 weiß
gibt man dem paar und werden uns
hoffentlich morgen bei dem huth wieder
mit echt mega kapitalia bis ganz hinauf
gerne wurde und diese ganze wohnung hier
zu zeigen wollten auf jeden fall genau
die überstellung abhängig macht aber
jetzt auch in sachen leisten also das
lohnt sich auf jeden fall wollte ich
mein video sagen